Vic
Cyborg.
Vic the...
Vic the Cyborg.
Just Cyborg.
You seem tense.
What's up?
I know why
you asked me here.
You got the whole
Justice League
on your big
office space
type evaluations.
You're here
to fire me.
I know.
Go ahead and do it.
Vic.
Cyborg.
I would never
fire you.
In fact,
you're the
most useful member
of this team.
Really?
Yeah!
The lasers,
the plasma cannon
you fly.
I can fly.
You talk
to computers?
Mm hmm.
That's
the one that
blows me away
the most.
In fact,
I'd love to
see it in action.
You know,
not many people ask
to see
what I can do.
I'd love to help.
Right.
Mm hmm.
Cause uhh
my wireless
printer.
Your printer?
I tried
to connect it
to the Bat
computer,
and they still
can't talk
to each other.
And, yes,
they're on the
same wireless
network.
My personal WIFI
GOTHAMANDCHEESE21
What do you want
me to do about it?
I'd like some
tech support.
Oh, man.
I'm a
hyper advanced man
computer
that can interface
with
all electronics.
Not your personal
Geek Squad!
Nobody said,
Geek Squad.
You're not a squad.
You're just
one geek guy.
I’m not your geek guy.
Okay.
Forget
about my printer.
It is so cold
in here.
What do you want?
It's a Nest
thermostat
man I thought
it would help
if you could
tell it to make it
roasty toasty.
When you set a
schedule for it.
Because it will
work on its own.
You just got to
set the
schedule yourself.
OK, so you can do this.
This is what
I'm talking about.
No, I’m saying you can do this.
I think you can do this.
You can do this!
No, I can't.
It's easy!
I can't.
I'm not doing it.
OK, then can you help me
get a CD
onto my iPhone?
No, I cannot help
you get a CD
onto your iPhone.
I'm not your gen-z
nephew here
to teach you
about TikTok.
I'm a human being.
Are you sure?
I mean, a lot of us
think your
ding dong just
might be three
or four
D batteries.
Who said that?
Alfred.
Well, no,
I said it to Alfred.
Wouldn't
it be great
if Cyborgs
ding dong was three
or four
D batteries?
And he said,
very good, sir.
Can you just fire me
already.
Fire you?!
Cybees
honestly,
I would never
fire you.
All foolishness
aside,
I have a matter
of life and death
that only YOU
can help me with.
Really?
Really!
This is a grave
grave matter.
Okay,
tell me about it.
Okay.
I had some
documents,
photographs,
and I
deleted those
documents,
and I need
to retrieve them.
They're highly
sensitive.
And you need me
to access
the mainframe.
Get them. For me.
I know
there's got
to be a way.
Oh, there's
definitely a way.
Yes!
I can do this.
Really?
Yeah, just tell me what
the pictures are of.
Okay.
Well,
I don’t know if you ever met my
now dead
girlfriend,
Rachel Dawes.
Hmm
She’s lovely.
Sorry for your loss.
I appreciate that.
Before she passed
in a barrel fire,
she had sent me some
delicate
photographs.
Mhm
Nasty.
Delicious.
Let's just say.
And I
really
enjoyed them.
But after she died
in a barrel fire,
I felt
sort of
wrong
looking at the photos.
It would have been
very gross.
Yeah.
It felt disrespectful.
Hmm.
So, I deleted em.
Then.
Enough time passed.
Memory faded to legend.
And it no longer
feels disrespectful
to look at
the photos.
In fact,
it feels like a way
of honoring her
memory.
And
what do you want me to do?
Please retrieve
the photographs
that I might
resume
batsturbating
And thereby,
in the Viking tradition
keep her memory
alive.
You want me
to help you
find your dead
girlfriend photos
so that you can
batsturbate?
You know, I'd look at it,
give my ding dong
a few batarangs.
Pow!
Bam!
J*zzz!
OK, how is THIS
a matter of life
and death?
Stress is a killer.
You try perching
on a gargoyle
for 12 hours
looking for
Killer Croc
in case he
takes surface streets.
You’re tense up there,
no chance.
But if you're drained
and I mean drained
The way that only a
photo of a naked girlfriend
who died in
a barrel fire
can drain?
Now you’re fightin’ crime.
NOW YOU’RE FIGHTIN’ CRIME.
They told me you were a psychopath
and I did not believe it.
I am not helping
you with that.
Then you’re f*ckin fired.
You can't fire me.
I quit.
You can't
control alt delete
the Justice League.
Hell, yes I can.
Understand I’ve see your
dating profile too.
You’re sick.
Before you go.
Cyborg
Play
smooth jazz.
** smooth jazz music **
So embarrassed that
that worked.
Cyborg, stop.
Cyborg,
resume.
** smooth jazz music **
Cyborg, stop.
Cyborg, resume
volume ten.
** smooth jazz music  loud **
F*ck you Batman.
Cyborg,
repeat this song.